[Music]
on this Friday night growing calls to
search a Manitoba landfill for murdered
indigenous women Winnipeg Police say it
can't be done but a retired cop says
it's been done before by the time we
were done we had actually gone through
more material than did the World Trade
Center
Healthcare cash the provincial pleas and
the fed's ultimatum
badly needed boost the new shot in the
arm approved for Canadian kids plus he's
not a Mean One
The Grinch Who Stole Santa's Thunder
powwow dancing on a Saskatchewan First
Nation
global national with far NASA reporting
tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us operations at a Winnipeg area
landfill have now stopped while
officials there consider whether and how
to search for murdered indigenous women
who are believed to be buried there the
task is Monumental involving acres of
land but it wouldn't be the first case
to see police comb through such a large
area as Melissa Ridgid reports the
investigation is also sparking
speculation about whether more victims
might be buried there
this is the Prairie green landfill
believed to be the resting place of at
least two murdered indigenous women an
Advocates fear there may be more but
they don't want this to be anyone's
final resting place demanding a search
to give the women dignity and their
families closure Winnipeg Police believe
the bodies of Morgan Harris and Mercedes
Myron are somewhere in a Four Acre area
here under at least 40 feet of heavy
construction mud animal remains and
asbestos it's not known where the body
of an unidentified woman is but yet
another victim 24 year old Rebecca
Contour was discovered after a
month-long search at a different
landfill Perry green has stopped
operations while politicians figure out
how a search would take shape given the
fact that the communities just come
through the residential school system
and the unmarked Graves we have to be
sensitive to that it's far from the
first time investigators would face an
exhaustive search in a homicide case
each with unique challenges they're
going to have to gather the people
together that know what they're doing
and know how to do this we relied
heavily on Academia we had 102 I think
students come in to help out
and so you're going to have to be
organized with the people and the
qualified people to come in to do the
work meanwhile missing murdered
indigenous women and girls Advocates say
they're looking into other missing women
who might be a known homicide victims
it's suspected that the man accused of
killing these four indigenous women was
targeting homeless shelters Global News
spoke with his estranged wife I had gone
to Siloam
um
of struggling with uh drug addiction at
the time
and I was waiting to get a bed I sat
down beside me and she was
seemed to be you know like a
nice friendly person I made the choice
instead of staying for about its little
mission to go home
or go to this apartment
uh which became my home after we do
believe and we are looking into if there
is any other women
uh missing and who they are and if they
were someone who accessed The Shelter
Systems we want to ensure that there is
no other women that could potentially be
in that landfill and we suspect there
could be Melissa Ridge in Global News
Winnipeg
police in Toronto have identified the
woman killed and what they're calling a
random stabbing at a busy subway station
31 year old Vanessa karpuska died in
hospital after a man stabbed her and
another woman yesterday the second woman
was injured but has since been released
from hospital a 52 year old suspect was
arrested at the station police say he
did not know the victims
a warning tonight about a major data
breach involving Ontario's vaccine
management system the provincial
government is notifying about 360
000 people that personal data including
names and phone numbers was stolen back
in November of last year and potentially
given to fraudsters two people have now
been charged the province insists the
booking system is monitored regularly
and is secure the BC government has
launched a flu vaccine Blitz focusing on
children
more walk-in clinics open today across
the province and will run through the
weekend six deaths have now been linked
to influenza among Children and Youth in
BC this season BC's top doctor says the
unusual pattern has prompted officials
there to begin providing weekly updates
on pediatric flu related deaths
Canada's premiers are demanding the
federal government do more to help
struggling Children's Hospitals they're
calling for an urgent meeting with the
Prime Minister early in the new year to
discuss funding the provincial and
territorial leaders say they're paying a
disproportionate amount for health
services and the costs are skyrocketing
now for its part the federal government
says it's open to increasing the Canada
Health transfer so what's the sticking
point Mackenzie gray joins us now with
more Mackenzie Jeff all sides agree
there is a health care crisis but the
solution has come back to an age-old
fight the premier is demanding more
money for Health Care the federal
government only willing to cough it up
if they play by ottawa's rules what
we're calling for today is just a
meeting to sit down with the prime
minister to have the discussion about a
fair uh and sustainable funding for the
future of Health Care in our country all
13 premiers demanding a meeting with the
prime minister to discuss their health
care proposal an increase of 28 billion
dollars annually to the Canada Health
transfers with no strings attached it's
a deal Health Minister Jean Eve duclow
won't even entertain a plan to set on
conditional transfers to hell to to
finance ministers is not a Health Plan
Ottawa says they're willing to give
billions to the provinces but they want
it spent on sectors like long-term care
and Mental Health Plus they want the
provinces to do a better job of sharing
Health Data objectives do close as
provincial Health ministers are on board
with now we need premiers to let us do
our job and express publicly the type of
outcomes and results that we need to
achieve together while the political
debate continues the triple threat of
RSV influenza and covid is straining a
Health Care System already grappling
with a massive Staffing shortage the
latest sign of collapse a record number
of children being transferred by air
ambulance in Ontario in November alone
140 pediatric patients switch hospitals
via orange air ambulance with plans now
being made to potentially move patients
to New York State or Michigan I think
it's not that's our secret that there's
seems to be a significant
strain in the system with regard to
respiratory illness specifically amongst
pediatric patients in Ottawa the
Children's Hospital of eastern Ontario
has called in the Red Cross to help and
a pediatric Hospice in Calgary has
temporarily closed sending staff to a
local children's hospital everyone feels
overwhelmed and the system is
overwhelmed uh you know there's just
massive demands on all aspects of the
system Duke Lowe wouldn't say if the
Prime Minister would meet with the
premiers and that's because the federal
government could be changing their
strategy on health care with Ottawa
trying to sign unilateral deals with
provinces instead of negotiating with
them as a group Jeff
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
and parents now have a new tool to help
protect their children against this
overwhelming respiratory illness season
Health Canada has just approved a new
covid-19 bivalent booster for Canadian
kids
the move now enables children aged 5 to
11 to receive the Pfizer biontech
booster shot designed to protect against
the more infectious ba-4 and five
Omicron subvariants Health Canada says
the dosage one-third the amount given to
those age 12 and up was found to be safe
and effective for the younger age group
Quebec's legislature has passed a law
ending the requirement for members to
swear an oath to the king the new law
comes days after three elected party
Quebec War members refused to swear the
oath and were then barred from entering
the assembly room previously Quebec
members of the legislature had to swear
two Oaths one to the people of Quebec
and another to the crown the oath to the
crown is now optional
Ukraine's Ministry of defense is taking
to Twitter to thank Canada for its help
with the war effort
[Music]
for sure
with a familiar soundtrack from Canada's
Bachmann Turner overdrive the video says
thank you for Canadian shipments of
military supplies and yes long underwear
and those extra layers are key is a
brutally cold winter takes hold
Ukrainian soldiers are now engaged in
some of the most intense battles of the
war near the eastern city of bakmut
meanwhile The Diplomatic war between
Russia and the West is also intensifying
with Canada and the Kremlin announcing
new sanctions Europe bureau chief
Crystal gomancing Reports
in the woods around bakmut Ukrainian
infantry troops are digging in
battles in the besieged Donetsk region
have fresh ferocity
with Russian and Ukrainian troops just
100 meters apart in some places
this volunteer says he made it to the
ice crusted grounds of the city he
describes fires and constant explosions
Thursday he was handing out food and
imploring residents to leave
this woman expressed love and gratitude
but stays
for systematic human rights violations
against Russians opposing the war in
Ukraine Canada just sanctioned 33
current and former Russian officials a
move that led Moscow to summon Canada's
Ambassador meanwhile ukrainians face
inconceivable violence day in and day
out yeah
it was a very loud noise I barely
managed to close the doors and get the
children before the ceiling started to
crumble the walls as well British prime
minister Rishi sunak spoke with
Ukraine's president assuring him more
defensive weapons are on the way
in his nightly addressed Vladimir
zielinski thanked the UK for its support
and expressed the challenges faced by
those on the front lines in the east
in an effort to continue its bloody war
on Ukraine British officials accuse
Russia of cozying up to Iran Russia is
now attempting to obtain more weapons
including hundreds of ballistic missiles
in return
in return
Russia is offering Iran an unprecedented
level of military and technical support
Russia denies that allegation just as
Iran denies selling Kamikaze drones to
the Kremlin after the February invasion
Crystal gomancing Global News London
Russia's war in Ukraine is largely to
blame for a surge in the number of
journalists killed on the job in 2022 in
a new report the International
Federation of journalists says 67 media
workers have been killed around the
world so far this year that's 20 more
than all of last year 12 deaths in
Ukraine made that country the most
dangerous But Rising violence in Haiti
and Mexico are also being blamed for the
spike the group also says that at least
375 journalists are currently imprisoned
because of their work with the most in
China Myanmar and turkey
fresh frustration in the fight to
resettle Afghan refugees
coming up the cap Canada is now imposing
when the Taliban reclaimed control of
Afghanistan in the summer of 2021 tens
of thousands fled the country but many
others could not and have been trying
desperately to escape ever since Canada
has welcomed more than 25 thousand
Afghans since the Taliban takeover and
it recently quietly launched a new
program to help those without documents
but as nithugacha explains the temporary
program to sponsor Afghan refugees has
been stopped just weeks after it started
when the Taliban recaptured Afghanistan
in August of 2021 Canadians wanted to
help those fleeing for their lives and
thousands remain at the ready to support
Asylum Seekers we as a committee have
all the resources to be able to support
this family we just need the help to get
them here but there's a big obstacle in
order to be privately sponsored the
Canadian government requires most
Afghans who fled to other countries like
Pakistan and Iran to have official
Refugee recognition from that foreign
state or from the UN High commission for
refugees though they meet the definition
of a refugee official status is
something very few Afghans are able to
obtain in part because with that status
comes protections from states that are
often unwilling to provide them we've
been working with them for over a year
that's why so many sponsors like this
church group in London Ontario jumped at
a temporary Federal program that
launched on October 17th waiving the
need for That official Refugee status as
long as they meet the Canadian
government's criteria to be privately
sponsored so we were scrambling over the
last six weeks to get our applications
together but in those six weeks after it
launched the program reached its cap of
3 000 refugees leaving many like Stephen
watt frustrated and wondering why an
arbitrary limit exists when the need is
so high it's a crushing blow to many
many people across the country who are
still preparing these applications
because it's their only hope to get
people out we know it filled up 20
minutes half an hour in messages came
that the inbox was full
so we know there was a high demand if
our condo rajabi coordinates an Afghan
response initiative in BC from
Afghanistan herself she came to Canada
in 2017 as a refugee having been
targeted for her work as a prominent
women's rights activist we hope that the
government could ease if the
requirements for these refugees together
these groups are calling on Ottawa to
remove the cap but immigration Minister
Sean Fraser told Global News that's not
happening we don't currently have plans
to extend it to further numbers because
it it would eat away at the allocations
that are already committed to other
groups who are working to sponsor people
as well funds are being raised by by
their family and friends and other
caring volunteers it's not coming out of
the government's pocket so I don't know
why you would handicap it with with a
limit like this these groups now trying
to partner with others across the
country to continue appealing to the
feds to accept applications under this
temporary program program for a full
year nitu Garcia Global News Vancouver
critical minerals still ahead the new
plan to power Canada's transition
towards Green Technology
Ottawa is facing pressure to speed up
its regulatory decisions on critical
minerals if the government wants to meet
its climate goals and keep up with the
growing demand for Green Technology
natural resources Minister says the
minerals are essential to power Canada's
transition away from fossil fuels Eric
Sorensen reports
natural resources helped build Canada's
modern industrial economy and now the
country's geologic abundance will be
exploited to fuel a newer and Greener
economy
Ottawa plans to speed up regulatory
approval for critical minerals used in
everything from solar panels to Electric
batteries the last federal budget
committed almost 4 billion dollars to a
new strategy to help Canada keep up with
International demand and competition
simply put there is no energy transition
without critical minerals Canada can
choose to be a leader in the global
economic shift or we can let it happen
to us across Canada there are dozens of
projects and mines in almost all
provinces and territories Canada's
resource abundance totals 31 critical
minerals including priority minerals
lithium copper and rare earth minerals
along with ores like Cobalt nickel and
graphite one of the most promising
regions is the ring of fire in Northern
Ontario and throughout the process from
exploration to mining to battery
development to full-scale manufacturing
and finally to recycling
Ottawa wants to cut red tape to get
projects moving take the ring of fire
critical minerals were discovered more
than decade ago yet approval and
eventual mining are still years away
here the world is looking for Canadian
resources and right now the regulatory
system definitely gets uh gets in the
way but projects won't happen overnight
many minerals lie in traditional
indigenous lands projects will require
consultation and partnership the key to
success in this sector will be finding
mineral extraction or processing
arrangements with First Nations that
include meaningful benefits and free
prior and informed consent it is a
tricky balance just this week Ottawa and
General Motors announced the country's
first full-scale electric vehicle
manufacturing plant e-vehicles will help
the climate but the minerals they
require must be mined where biodiversity
is also at risk and an emphasis on
regulatory speed worries environmental
groups and I think a lot of the
communities that are currently being
affected by mining want to better
regulations not deregulation agenda it's
a balance Ottawa will try to get right
to support a new and growing economy and
still meet Canada's climate goals Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
up next why bringing holiday cheer to
indigenous kids is a cinch when you're a
dancer known as the pow-wow Grinch
welcome back a little girl in California
has just been granted a unicorn license
Yes you heard that right Madeline made
the request to La's Animal Control
authorities last month she was sent a
heart-shaped tag with the words
permanent unicorn license as well as a
unicorn toy and certificate now the
license states that if Madeleine finds
her unicorn it must be given ample
exposure to sunlight Moon beams and
rainbows and have its horn polished at
least once a month good luck to Madeline
in her search as children count the days
before Santa Claus makes his rounds the
Grinch has stolen Christmas hearts on a
Saskatchewan First Nation chance bear
also known as the pow-wow Grinch brings
a unique First Nations flavor to the
well-known Dr Seuss character and as
Heather York's West tells us his touring
performances are quickly becoming a
beloved holiday tradition Max
by the time
it was a little something that caught
fire during the pandemic
those Clover times they weren't you know
they're all in lockdown so we decided to
make this parade and go out to all the
local First Nations
[Music]
you know chapaway's First Nations father
of three first put on the homemade
costume in 2017 but it wasn't long
before words spread because Chance
Bear's character was no ordinary Grinch
[Music]
the powwow Grinch was distinctly
indigenous did such a joy to watch and
to witness our culture coming into play
through the Grinch he definitely has
stole Christmas from Santa Claus on a
Choppa waste Nation
a former pow-wow chicken dancer in his
youth bear says he felt compelled by the
cringe to dance the cleansing grass
stance instead is it because the Grinch
kind of looks like grass
baby in the floor of the flow of the fur
and all that the dancing pow-wow Grinch
has now become a fixture at indigenous
parties in South Saskatchewan with
dancing videos going viral especially
when the Grinch goes toe-to-toe with the
big guy himself
[Music]
he actually put Santa to shame
bear juggles his Grinchy gigs during his
furnace company's busy season because he
says it's a labor of love an opportunity
to spread joy and Indigenous Pride
during a time when everyone can use a
little extra cheer Heather York's West
Global News Calgary
that story made my heart grow three
sizes that is global national for this
Friday I'm Jeff sepel tonight your
Canada is Montreal lit up for the
holiday season we love seeing your
Canada so please send your festive
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great night
foreign
[Music]